an emotional reunion at the Greek Port
of Kalamata eighteen-year-old Muhammad
was pulled from the Mediterranean on
Wednesday
now he's been found by his brother who
traveled here from the Netherlands
Muhammad had been in Libya for almost
two years before he made the dangerous
Journey how old is he
I
now is
Mohammed was among up to 750 people
believed to be packed onto this fishing
boat when it capsized only 104 people
were rescued most were from Syria Egypt
and Pakistan it's an agonizing wait for
their families back home
all we want is to hear his voice make
sure he's okay if authorities wanted to
afford him let them let him come back
Among Us here because we're in hell
since the day this happened we haven't
heard a thing
as soon as my brother got into the ball
he said 50 people fit in here and they
were put in 750 people he said he's 100
sure he will take in water I told him to
get off don't go and he said the mafia
doesn't let us get off they have guns
they have knives they were forcing
people in
some survivors and officials have
claimed the boat capsized after the
Coast Guard attached a rope to it
government denies that's what caused the
sinking and says the passengers refused
help
the tragedy has sparked protests across
Greece critics accuse the government of
being complicit by not creating safe and
legal ways for people to seek Asylum the
un's human rights Chief is calling for
action
the High Commissioner reiterated his
call to states to open up more regular
migration channels
enhance responsibility sharing ensure
arrangements for the safe And Timely
disembarkation of all people rescued at
Sea the number of migrants crossing the
Mediterranean has doubled compared to a
year ago the survivors of this shipwreck
are being assessed by immigration
authorities and if they're not entitled
to protection risk being deported
Alexandra Byers Al Jazeera